what's the weirdest thing you've ever
done in your hotel room
what's that slapping sound
Spidey's hands stick to everything
so this masturbation game has you a -
check out those special dark chocolate
nips it shove it up before wearing
spandex I get it the guy has no parents
give him a break you know people forget
spider-man as a teenager who's still
discovering his body you'll never
believe who he's sharing a room with
mouth gaping just kidding there are
geneticists they didn't have the Daily
Bugle so I got you USA Today and I made
you a waffle you better leave a tip for
the cleaning ladies when you're on the
comic-con circuit rooms fill up quick
are you trying to shatter the glass
ceiling or just crawl around on top of
it are you afraid of spiders a little
bit you don't like them spiders creepy
agreed now have you ever gotten hurt no
like just bruises scratches do you have
good balance no really no how does that
work out for you yeah I did I like
really clumsy but have you ever tripped
while you were up on top of a rooftop
you have I was kind of like running
across and they had like these wires on
the top and I didn't see it so I kind of
just faced by it but not off the edge no
I never had any close calls in the edge
not really nice can you do a pull-up
icon you can't do okay that's what I
want to hear when you're up on top of a
crane that you couldn't if you did fall
do a single pole to save your life who's
filming you I'm usually a my boyfriend
you think that he's hoping for that
ultimate video you think you keep
filming um that thought has crossed my
mind
I'm not sure hope so there's nothing
worse than when something goes wrong and
the cameraman shuts the camera off even
if you drop it let us hear the sounds
seemed the Earth's Yellow Sun turns
Superman into a super freak
after a couple of weeks the fortress of
solitude starts to get to you is he
filling it with air or semen but he also
has a chunk of Kryptonite shoved up his
pooper start with ugly women being on
television now here we are fat
superheroes
Thank You Obama Supes not the only kinky
member of the Justice League Batman gets
off on being treated like a baby holy
stink bombs does Batman have to go potty
clean my butt cave Robin somebody's got
an upset tummy it's what's in my diaper
that defines me
must be an orphan thing welcome to Las
Vegas the economy is hurting everyone
even Bruce Wayne had to take a job
handing out titty bar coupons on the
strip Oh looks like there's some trouble
in Sin City and I'm not just talking
about Jeff Dunham's upcoming appearance
we're about to watch Batman face his
toughest foe yet a liquored up cholo
Batman just told him to suck his mother
that's definitely Christian Bale that
guy's got a temper riddle me this
where's Boy Wonder when you need him
probably at town making out with one of
the hot male bartenders that I know
nothing about holy bitch-slap you should
know better than to pick a fight with a
dark night that's how Heath Ledger died
the irony a spine injury was the same
thing that paralyzed Superman this is
why no one in the UFC fights with a cape
sure it looks amazing but it's really
restricted so hard when you realize your
heroes only a human and most likely
homeless
oh he's wobbly but that might just be
because he's drunk we're just glad that
Christopher Nolan didn't make this clip
three hours too long and for that we
thank you
you